شيعه اهالي مدينه جنين الفتاه جنى ذكرنا
التي استشهدت برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في وقت سابق اليوم وضحت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه
برصاصه في الراس اطلقها جنود الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامهم منطقه البيادر بمدينه جنين
حيث اعتقلوا ثلاثه شبان بينهم اسرى محررون
في الوقت نفسه شنت قوات الاحتلال حمله
اعتقالات في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه والقدس وقالت انها ستواصل العمل
لاحباط ما وصفته بالارهابي في كل مكان
معنا من رام الله
البديري اهلا بك
تنقل لنا الوضع في جنين مع استمرار هذه
الحملات من قبل القوات الاحتلال وايضا لن
يعرج على مراسم تشيعه جنى
الجنازه انتهت شركه بها اهالي مدينه ومخيم
جنين المشيعون الذين حملوا نعش الشهيده
الطفله جنى زكارنه والبالغه من العمر 16
عاما رددوا الشعارات التي تطالب بالانتقام
وايضا تؤكد على مواصله المقاومه حتى يتمكن
الجميع من العيش بامان دون احتلال هذه بعض
الشعارات التي رددوها ولكن الاحدث الان ما
جاء على لسان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بني
جانس الذي حسب وصفه اعرب عن اسفه لمقتل
الفتاه جنى ولكنه قال ان جاء ذلك ردا على
اطلاق النار على جنود الاحتلال من ذات
الموقع اي انه يقول بان همم لا احد من همم
الجنود الاسرائيليين يقومون بقتل اي شخص
ليس متورط بالارهاب حسب همم وصفه وان
عمليه همم القتل جاءت خلال عمليه دعم
واعتقال لمن وصفهم بالارهابيين وانه كان
هناك اطلاق نار اتجاه جنود الاحتلال من
هذه المنطقه والقاء عبوات ناسفه واضطر
الجنود للدفاع عن انفسهم باطلاق النار
مشابها ذلك بما يحدث من القاء الفلسطينيين
للحجاره على سيارات المستوطنين وبالطبع
الفلسطينيين يروا ان هناك فرق شاسع في هذه
الاثناء ايضا ملف الطفله جنى الذي بدا
يتفاعل خلال الساعه الماضيه بشكل اكبر بعد
الاعلان من قبل معهد الطب العدلي بان
الرصاصه التي اخترقت راس الطفله جنى همم
هو رصاص اسرائيلي قدم وزير الخارجيه
الفلسطيني رياض المالكي للممثله الخاصه
للامين العام للامم المتحده المعنيه
بالاطفال وانزاعات همم غامبيا همم فرجينيا
غامبيا التي تزور المنطقه وهي مختصه بهمم
قضيه الاعتداء على الاطفال قدم لها الملف
بدء الطفله جنى والتاكيد على ان هناك اكثر
من 52 طفلا قتلهم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال هذا العام وحده وكل الجرائم نحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من 219 شهيدا سقطوا منذ
بدايه هذا العام من بينهم 167 في الضفه
الغربيه من بين الشهداء كان العدد الاكبر
في جنين تحديدا نتحدث عن اكثر من همم
تقريبا 50 همم 55 شهيدا من مدينه ومخيم
جنين هذه الزياره للممثله الخاصه للامم
المتحده زياره مهمه
للتاكيد على ان ما يتم على الارض هو اعدام
بدم بارد اتجاه
اطفال الذين حتى وان كانوا يتواجدون في
موقع خطر فذلك بسبب اقتحامات قوات
الاحتلال للاعتقال او للمذاهبه من رام
الله مراسله الجزيره جبال البديري شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]